do you know what this is huh huh he said
I've had then you would be a hundred
percent correct and I'm going to do a
live unboxing well it's not really alive
because I am shooting this and editing
it but we're about to unbox the
first-ever iPad Mini
you guys ready that's it done let's see
what's inside this box Thunderbolt cable
beast and Bishu brick now the moment
that we've all been waiting for
iPad Mini so you guys might first notice
about the iPad Mini is much much much
much much smaller let's start it up so I
was starting up him to do a size
comparison to the iPad 2 so firstly I've
had to win fares in iPad Mini as you can
tell is significantly smaller I'm
actually quite surprised how small it
really is do you guys see this is this
for real this is the iPad Dracon mini ok
let's start it up let's see what it
looks like it looks the same just hey
guys no this was actually the iPhone I
did an actual unboxing on my reviews
channel so feel free to go check it out
where is it the iPhone next to it so
obviously it is much better than the
iPhone but it's much smaller than the
iPad is a little awkward here we go
I mean what you guys think um that's it
I love you bye